la fête de l'internet tout cette fin de
semaine plus d'un milliers d'initiatives
dans toute la france pour faire
connaître et faire aimer ce nouveau
moyen de communication qui est en soi
une véritable révolution révolution qui
touchent tous les domaines y compris
celui du commerce
on peut désormais tout acheté et ou
vendre sur internet jean claude allanic
andreï sera une envie de fêter le
printemps en pleine nuit en commandant
des fleurs sur internet tout est
possible et tout est ouvert 24 heures
sur 24
il suffit de surfer à la recherche d'un
centre commercial virtuel comme celui ci
qui rassemble 650 boutiques où on trouve
de tout un simple clic sur la souris et
le consommateur peut commencer sa partie
de shopping électronique
parmi les sites les plus fréquentés les
boutiques de 20
et comme tout se passe sur l'ordinateur
sans ouvrir de magasins c'est autant
d'économies pour les commerçants et les
consommateurs via moins d'intermédiaires
entre nous et le client final et on est
capable de faire bénéficier au client
final de conditions plus avantageuses
revers de la médaille le risque de
piratage
quand on paye avec une carte bancaire
pour contrer cette nouvelle forme de
banditisme informatique
le gouvernement vient d'ailleurs
d'autoriser le cryptage pour des
paiements sécurisés un paiement sécurisé
c'est un transfert d'informations
confidentielles entre l'ordinateur du
client donc de l'internaute et le site
marchand
donc là le numéro de carte bleue par
exemple est crypté pendant le transfert
entre l'ordinateur du client et le site
marchand l'insécurité qui devrait donner
un coup de fouet aux ventes et placer le
commerce électronique au même niveau que
la vente par correspondance classique
avec l'atout particulier d'internet
pouvoir écouter et voir avant de
s'embarquer dans un achat
une envie de fêter le printemps en
pleine nuit en commandant des fleurs sur
internet tout est possible et tout est
ouvert 24 heures sur 24
il suffit de surfer à la recherche d'un
centre commercial virtuel comme celui ci
qui rassemble 650 boutiques où on trouve
de tout un simple clic sur la souris et
le consommateur peut commencer sa partie
de shopping électronique par les
huissiers qui fréquentent et les
boutiques de 20 et comme tout se passe
sur l'ordinateur sans ouvrir de magasins
le temps des communistes commerçants et
les consommateurs via moins
d'intermédiaires entre nous et le client
final et on est capable de faire
bénéficier au client final de conditions
plus avantageuses
revers de la médaille le risque de
piratage haute on paye avec une carte
bancaire
pour contrer cette nouvelle forme de
banditisme informatique
le gouvernement vient d'ailleurs
d'autoriser le cryptage pour des
paiements sécurisés ont tellement
sécurisé c'est un transfert
d'informations confidentielles entre
l'ordinateur du client donc de
l'internaute et le site marchand
donc là le numéro de carte bleue par
exemple est crypté pendant le transfert
entre l'ordinateur du client et le site
marchand sécurité qui devrait donner un
coup de fouet aux ventes et placer le
commerce électronique au même niveau que
la vente par correspondance musique
avec l'atout particulier d'internet
pouvoir écouter et voir avant de
s'embarquer dans 1h
non